you're not uncomfortable like being
naked you know like what depends on the
setting sometimes I think it's like
super funny you think being nude is
funny oh very funny
yeah what am I one of one a something I
used to do a lot then I stopped was I
thought is this this could go anywhere
this sounds like there are detectives
watching that are leaning forward now
looking for that guy I used to go into
kind of like public restrooms yes at
urinal I'd stand at a urinal
yeah and pull my pants all the way down
like a kid but like a grown man I would
do this and and you don't expect to see
it right it's funny to me that's funny
bronze I have just say a grown man doing
that it's funny but you're owning this
in public
well I was usually like with it for the
benefit of like a friend that I'm you
know might be peeing with but you know I
the last time I did it I was on a I was
on a press tour with Jason Segel and we
were at this much music I remembers in
Canada I was like there MTV we're in the
we were in there I just have to use the
restroom for week before we go on air
and I knew he was gonna go to the
bathroom too so I ran in first and I did
it and there was no one else in the
bathroom I was standing up just like
completely you know right bare-assed
standing at the at the Earl and the door
opens and it was just like some guy it
wasn't Seagal no and and so I was in the
bathroom by myself
[Laughter]
and was legitimately freaked out I said
his expression was oh and then I was so
freaked out that I didn't even play it
off funny and I said oh I thought it was
going to be somebody else which was not
nothing to say and then I Jason never
even came in right today and then I
walked out and I just saw that guy
talking to some people that he worked
with with like all ashen face is living
off that story he's telling everyone he
knows that Paul Rudd you know public
restrooms yeah
I wish you'd shuffled out with your
pants around your ankles hey thanks for
watching be sure to click subscribe to
see even more great Conan clips you may
now return to your pirated movies and
creepy Japanese pornography